good evening I'm welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight is you have no doubt
seen earlier today Special Counsel
Robert Muller's investigation unveiled
13 separate indictments against Russian
citizens who allegedly tried to meddle
in the 2016 election you're going to
hear a massive amount of propaganda
about those indictments and what they
mean in coming days so we've looked at
them carefully and here's what seems to
be true about them the indictments
describe a Russian effort to quote sow
discord in the American political system
this effort began in 2014 that was of
course before Donald Trump or any other
candidate had declared for the
presidential race the effort didn't seem
to have a particular ideological agenda
the point was to stir up trouble during
the 2016 race these 13 Russians
allegedly ran Facebook ads and tried to
organize events that criticized Hillary
Clinton and supported Donald Trump but
the Russians also supported some left
wingers like Bernie Sanders and black
lives matter Hillary Clinton was the
frontrunner for most of the race and
they wanted to yank her chain and they
did but once the election was over the
Russians immediately started organizing
rallies against Donald Trump rallies
that was probably an overstatement an
anti-muslim event for example allegedly
organized by the Russians drew a total
of four RSVPs an anti Hillary event in
New York got just 45 the only really
successful event the Russians appeared
to have pulled off seems to be an anti
Trump rally in New York City after the
election right outside Trump Tower now
all of this is annoying obviously
they're foreigners but none of it seems
momentous here's what's not of the
indictments any evidence at all that any
Russian behavior changed a single vote
or did anything to sway the election in
any direction Deputy Attorney General
rod Rosenstein admitted as much today
watch there is no allegation in this
indictment that any American was a
knowing participant in this illegal
activity there is no allegation in the
indictment that the charge conduct
altered the outcome of the 2016 election
in a statement this afternoon the White
House even boasted about today's news
quote President Donald J Trump has been
fully briefed on this matter and is glad
to see the special counsels
investigation further indicates that
there was no collusion between the Trump
campaign and Russia and that's basically
true close to 20 people have been
indicted in this investigation so far
still not a single piece of evidence at
the Trump campaign colluded with Putin
collusion you'll remember was the reason
we supposedly needed this multi-year
multi-million dollar investigation in
the first place the one that is
basically ground Washington to a halt
and put your concerns on the back burner
and yet the evidence unearthed so far
suggests precisely the opposite of
collusion